bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
alors je voudrais avec un nouvel invité
dans ce championnat de france 2015 à
saint quentin c'est bien entendu le
grand maître international que vous avez
reconnu tout de suite au romain edouard
salut romain salut contenta journée la
côte première victoire allait commencer
ouais c'était pas évident qu'il aime et
on a du temps à ta partie face à
jean-marc degraeve sur des gones atv et
c'était une partie tendue je crois que
tu as quelques tu t'es trompé un peu
c'est sa nature mais j'ai vu j'ai vu
exactement comment gagner
en gros pour faire simple jeu de façon
gagner pour ce conte la position donc
l'une avec d'alger 5 super que cet échec
ou une avec dan fields à mach 4 au 5 et
cabrio pcistes comme j'ai comme j'aurais
pu faire dans la partie et on voit ce
qui s'est passé c'est qu'à ce moment là
je suis ici je suis sorti de la salle
premier médicament je suis revenu et
j'ai mélangé les deux variantes j'ai
joué d'un match 4 5 et cabrio set je
fais un espèce d'amalgamé des deux
variantes qui mangent pas du tout alors
que j'avais vu très exactement comment
gagner ceux qui m'ont vu très énervé
après la partie et avaient dû exactement
pouvons gagner tu t'es mélanger et jean
marc trouve une magnifique défense aussi
à la fin vous 17 un peu inattendu aussi
via un prisme ne pas le prendre pour la
table pour être honnête
c'est parce que c'est assez pour qu'à la
fin j'ai un peu fou 17 ici parce que en
revanche quand j'ai fait de repenser à
cet échec il peut aussi jouer fossé tout
17 tout de suite à tort qu'en 17 3 gbit
la différence c'est que j'ai plus qu'une
qualité - la classe et à claire mais
donc j'ai vu l'idée est quand images et
roger hué j'avais trente secondes devant
de toute façon je pense que la position
déjà perdu à ce moment là je n'étais pas
du tout ce que j'avais prévu de faire
fortune et membre de l'équipe de france
et tu as déjà un titre de champion de
france en titre partagé 3 en 2012 vous
êtes 4 a partagé le titre français ça à
pau le membre de l'équipe de france ça
donne des responsabilités sa responsable
lui passer un gros motif une compétition
qu'ils adorent jouer on a vraiment été
inspirés texte ordinaire surtout surtout
depuis quelques années et
oui mes responsabilités oui c'est comme
une saine compétition stressante on n'a
vraiment pas envie de la jouer
je pense que tous les membres de
l'équipe on préfère majeur une
compétition individuelle qu'en équipe de
france
et puis que représente la france oui bah
vu septembre d'avoir les bords ça aussi
c'est sinon comme est tous des erreurs
en équipe de france mais effectivement
c'est toujours
commettre des erreurs quand ça pénalise
quatre autres joueurs plus un capitaine
c'est toujours on attend vie de la faire
à ce moment-là mais voilà c'est ce qui
fait le charme et la difficulté de la
compétition et quand on les joue comme
ça dans ce coup aussi tu vas être amené
à jouer tes partenaires l'équipe de
france ton sélectionnés en asie ça s'est
déjà fait ça c'est déjà fait donc c'est
spécial ça ces matches là bon elle
travaille pas on travaille pas ensemble
toute l'année c'est simplement voilà on
a ces deux semaines de communion tous
les ans donc on partage certaines choses
mais de toute façon mon voilà les
parties restent individuel on a tous un
répertoire différent donc j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup de choses qu'on partage pas
c'est normal ça servira à départager du
coup bon de toute façon le championnat
de france on joue contre tous les potes
parce que là je pense qu'on se connaît
tous entre nous et donc voilà de ce
point de vue là c'est pas un ton pas le
ton est plus agréable à jouer de ce
point de vue là mais voilà le tournoi
d'autres d'autres qualités aussi alors
on va voir ta partie du jour maintenant
donc face à jules moussa donc on client
quand même sérieux de l'association
nationale 2015 puisqu'ils sortent d'une
victoire extraordinaire en championnat
de france juniors noces sur neuf
parce que ça fait un peu un se méfie
quand même de jeu de dungeon qui gagne 9
sur 9 comme ça je sais que c'est un
joueur dangereux j'ai déjà perdu conclut
des parties anglais sont rapides et
voilà je sais que même quand m même
quand la position gagnante il faut faire
très attention faire très attention et
là c'est combien il était à l'affût de
ces l'affût de la moindre erreur portes
de la moindre opportunité donc voilà
aujourd'hui j'ai eu la chance parce
qu'il a répétée langue qu'il a déjà joué
à la ronde 2 donc il est j'avais un
petit peu bancal et voilà en plus le
fait qu'il ait déjà jeu d'un tournage
avait pu bien avait visé était de la
partie mon petit dauphin bon choix du
tout dedans il m'a dit qu'il savait que
c'était risqué mais qui voilà qu'il
avait envie de la banque quand même
parce qu'il aime beaucoup
alors on y va alors ça démarre par des
quêtes les quatre des cinq dessins qui
ont des goûts du cube elliott c4c 6 donc
si tu tousses l'âme slave qu'avaient les
f3 cavalli et 6 se révéler cette forme
on sent les pièces de 6 donc ça hein
surprotège le centre oui ben wallace une
seule chine subissent la vallée à
d'autres coûts des princes et 4 à 6 etc
oui la foulée 5 c'est un des deux
principaux avec le 3 quand les jouets
dépensé 4 donc ça c'est la défense binic
hcc le coup le grand corps plus
populaires ont tous joué aussi ashes
attaquant est fou on va pas regarder
tout vient de ça c'est trop long mais en
tout cas il nous a quand même comme un
pion en attendant vous mais moi tout ça
c'est dans une très très très théorique
est vraiment d
les deux parties à quatre baies 5 pour
protéger le pion précède de cinq hommes
biesheim se contourner de dessiner des
scènes d'album rock punk et alors le
problème on se dit bon l'autorié perdu
puisque vous aussi mais en fait non
voilà l'énorme richesse voilà on attaque
le fou en contrepartie donc là le fresh
gars tu recules g5 même classe que font
reculer videmment lecavalier mais encore
un peu bouger donc cavalier projet 5
c'est la grande barre en théorie qu on
prend le pied on n'a pas pensé à trifi
une pièce mais en fait c'est infosat
suffisent voilà que mon projet 5-fu
pranger 5e maintenant il n'y a plus le
ht pour un rush a'salfo une deuxième
fois donc ici cavaliers b17 et le coût
principal mais justement il a joué faux
et 7,1 me lève et je compterai andrei
istratescu il que tu estimes être
inférieur probablement d'accord donc
c'est vraiment bon en fait c'est pareil
sur cavaliers bel essai j'ai énormément
de variantes et gros problème de cette
ouverture c'est que les noirs doivent se
rappeler d'un million de choses pour
faire nul est vraiment une petite erreur
peut être fatale
c'est pas une ouverture qui me ferait
jouer avec les morts on va dire qu'il a
répétée quelque chose qui d'après ses
dires est difficile nous pour nous c'est
difficile amateurs parce que c'est que
ça nous paraissait vraiment compliqué on
a donné une pièce pour deux pions déjà
va falloir en pensant qu'au mal à
récupérer un mois après après 3,6 au
préfet c'est léger à égalité matérielle
c'est ce qui s'y passe il un oui puis on
sait vous il faut prendre mètres de
l'ambassade russe trop tard au plan et
maintenant voilà récement dresde est ce
que je faisais trois qu'un coup
intéressant là j'ai pris un f6 tout
appris donc tu avais préparé ça oui
j'avais préparé déjà ça parce que tu
avais vus on va expliquer au public
j'en ai vu parce qu'on n'est pas
forcément habitués nous de forcer votre
souris fard à joue à ce niveau là mais
tu avais vu forcément sa partie j'avais
vu sa partie est donc évidemment j'avais
révisé cette variante est sa seconde
c'est dans laquelle j'avais fait tourner
un ordinateur chez moi pendant peut-être
une ou deux semaines il ya déjà un ou
deux ans et donc voilà mais comme disait
le gros avantage qu'il ait déjà joué
c'est que j'ai pu réaliser parce qu'on a
beau passer des heures et des heures sur
une variante si on arrivait cependant la
partie des fois simplement c'est le
black-out total il est sûr et la moindre
erreur est fatale à la moindre erreur
peut être fatale ont en tout cas peut
permettre au noir d'égaliser sans
problème il faut vraiment se rappeler de
tout un tas de funès d'entreprendre six
mois il faut mieux j'ai joué j'ai trois
qu'un des principaux
voilà alors j'ai 3 on veut mettre le fou
ce congé d'eux n'a pas d'avenir ici
c'est ça oui c'est ça le fond g2 est
bien pour pour pourra taper ici c'est
évident ça fait plaisir comme les
menaces de cavaliers pro b 5e là il ya
quelques petits problèmes sur les
diagonales ça permet aussi de solidifier
le roi parce que sans jouer j'ai trois
et peut toujours y avoir des problèmes
sur la colonne h au moment de petit rat
oui c'est un coup extrêmement logique
est donc nécessaire presque nécessaire
bien d'autres ou à quatre ou deux
elle donne des deux filiales à chorus
yannis mallat c'est un des meilleurs
là il a joué un ordre de coûts il a joué
tout bessette je suis pas très certain 7
heures de coups parce que normalement
les joueurs jouent cavale est à six
coups j'ai deux foulées 7 qui retourne
dans la partie ici m'a donné
l'opportunité je vais car à lille 4 du
cavalier ces cinq ans avec l'adq à
décines qui attaquent le fric avec
quatre thèmes le set ça aurait pu être
sympa la partie
ce n'est pas la partie mais voilà c'est
ça qui m'a laissé notre opportunité
simplement voilà pour la partie je ne
savais pas
cela faisait exactement une différence
j'avais pas exactement envie de passer
pour un idiot a apporté aucun avantage
j'ai juste décidé de refuser de faire
retomber dans ma prépa parce que oui je
connaissais par coeur
oui certes donc on résume on tu as tu as
vu qu'il y avait l'opportunité de faire
un coup qui était peut-être meilleur
carioca mais que tu risques que tu
connaissais - dames 7
c'est une cata plus fous et le meilleur
c'est ce qu'avaient les premiers sets
le g2 j'ai capturé ce coup bessette qui
est comme ça par un petit peu enterrés
mais quand même une pièce importante
parce que les noirs vont jouer ces 5
donc je pense que c'était aussi
intéressant en tout cas là tu étais dans
ce que tu connais pas de problème auquel
à jouer cavalier à six qu'elle coûtera
qu'en fait si le kavé l'idée les meneurs
n'ont pas le temps de jouer qu'avec des
17 à cause de cavaliers pro b 5 alors
que la socam et des preuves et saint
curé grands axes entre théorie alors car
il prend de lycéens qui si oui
évidemment on peut pas reprendre celle
de phu trong baissière sous prend
attaque la tour et le cavalier c'est un
désastre donc évident ce genre de
questions et on peut faire ça sylvain
très théorique le plus ont des cats est
empressé alors que les prophéties la
forêt en un an j'ai pas pris un but 5
passes que prévu en europe c'est que
c'est un truc pour les non d'accord donc
ici j'ai joué cavalier ou quatre il faut
jouer tout de suite pour forcer la dame
à revenir sur cette voie là la deuxième
étoile et une fois que l'on évoqué les
nains peuvent mettre leur d'amérique en
matière de maillots alors l'intérêt de
la dame se lasser de protéger 17 aussi
trouvé mais alors pour l'instant moi je
préfère la voir recette qu'en est-il par
exemple la dame sept étaient forcés pour
éviter qu avec des défis ces chèques en
dessous mais ici ce qu'ils gagnent la
richesse et le fou mais cette dernière
n'est pas le choix donc là géré ok mais
là maintenant que thiro également au
quay du grand côté bien sûr oui et j'ai
joué h4 qui était
c'est un coup que j'avais réservé depuis
un certain temps mais qui entre temps
était joué je crois que c'est une partie
chronique à renault à oui donc c'est
déjà tu y joues à très haut niveau alors
à noter que ce pion leur works curien
super bien protéger ceux qui ont une
option pas si c'est à dire que là il ya
en face à rien donc en finale il peut
s'avérer décisif c'est l'option qui est
en général fait la différence en finale
dans cette position là et les dédales
cap sur f5 l'auberge le cavalier g5
keynes très bonnes cases pour le
cavalier a aussi ça quant au wef 5 on
peut mettre m l'enclavé sur une
quinzaine délogeables il est peinard ici
tranquillou citoyens tout à fait bon du
coup c'est par contre ça implique que
les meneurs ont le temps de faire ses 5
avec quelques petits problèmes sur la
colonne des c'est ce qu'il a fait oui
alors ça c'est un produit c'est vrai que
là il ya un cru très logique apparaît
fort parce que le fou libéré est là et
le plan avec la tête après le club
dernier qu'il est en prison il aya
midali tour dames donc on peut pas
s'amuser de prendre des signes non plus
donc il semblerait que les noirs ben ils
vont
après tout reprend des quatre vont
prendre avantage
le gros problème ce serait si j'avais le
temps de 32 ans décathlon y aurait
vraiment des problèmes du coup il est
important essayer de jouer à kate
parce qu'alors on va juste expliqué pour
les spectateurs pourquoi prendre du
plomb c'est encore plus fort parce qu'on
se retrouvait pion central passé soutenu
par une tour donc on est on est vissé
quoi on peut rien faire et en plus c'est
un pion supplémentaires aussi une pierre
de plus ça fait cher donc là il est là
quatre un coup fort c'est pour se sucrer
les problèmes et idée donc au prochain
coup et de sion bon il va commencer par
tour qui ont des qualités de maître le
pion ces quatre ans précise qu'après les
nerfs de matelas le temps de reprendre
du plan sur des cas on affirme gilles
desseigne et si on a faim on attache
avec ses quatre sources
et donc ces cas très faible ces archives
tibet simpson est bidon le pion c4 est
prenable mais dans mon cas de prise du
pion des ceux qui on va sauter aussi
quoi dans glee c'est moins grave si les
pions sont pas liés enfin bref enfin
tout cas bien plus y aller au delà les
nains peuvent permettre donc il a fait
tout reprendre 4 est logique on apprend
à daniel adam dans me2 b4 que c'est plus
ou moins forcé pour penser la seule
façon de garder le roi un petit peu
protégé donc sa b4 pourrait vite
évidemment toute ouverture parce qu
aucune façon qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
d'autre
il ya la menace apprend blessèrent on ne
va pas prendre nous-mêmes ans à 4 parce
que ça libère la tour c 4 va tomber
c'est bon pour les blancs maintenant il
faut garder les pieds mouillés et
boucher toute possibilité d'ouverture
sur le roi qui comme elle est un peu
dans les couronnes des résines un peu
dans les plans d'heure mais il est quand
même pour l'instant bien protégés et le
pian c4 aussi bien protégé donc il faut
quand même faire il faut aller il faut
vite réagir quand même oui à traîner
dans cette variante à chaque coup compte
oui avec la partie et chroniqueur au new
world in chronic je suis plus est et au
recteur sauf que j'ai joué oui jeu mais
j'ai joué tour a des seins que je
pensais plus précis alors lisez
d'accord et 21 plutôt que l'autre oui
c'est plus précis c'est plus précis on
al'impression salariés n'ayant ce qui
est très très profond c'est qu'après fou
des cinq ici alors si soudée sens il
faut des cinq cavaliers g55 et s'il y
avait une partie avec tours 8
et la tour la tour f / d un taureau 8 la
wii pour en fait pouvoir reprendre des
pions sur sur des 5
après faut prendre cinq fois les
derniers génèrent des recettes est ici
touré fut un des traits assez embêtant à
base de là si on prend du foulard pour
une grande option parce que ça va
protéger la nappe parce qu'on se demande
qu'est ce qu'elle vient faire là l'atout
elle vient protéger ce qui est ce qui
semble bon et là on peut rajouter une
tour c'est vraiment une passion alors
qu'il y avait une partie avec la tour
eiffe sur des uns et les blancs belge
voiture d un voilà c'est une position
compliquée donc ça c'est en tout cas
d'après moi oui une amélioration dans
notre cas on met cette tour si on avait
mis cet ouragan il fallait revenir alors
là les deux tours jours il ya d'ailleurs
une partie comme ça oui voilà non c'est
un des trucs c'est un désavantage
d'avoir pu réviser avant la partie de
petits détails comme ça
ça c'est pour une de ces voix là mais
c'est un état qui est assez important
ouais donc ok il n'a pas joué food et 5
il faut revenir ici l'ajout entourage
des huit tours on évite donc c'est
l'aliment principal
j'ai pris sur des cats prise donc là
évidemment on peut pas prendre du plomb
qu'il peut mais va perdre option c4 est
donc ça change tout on peut bien sûr
mais il ya dans prend ses quatre échecs
et c'est plus la même comme je disais
après dans les finales d'appui ont le
plein on en faisait le plein je peux
faire la différence il va faire dame
donc tout reprend point là et ici tour
c'est un tour 6 1 il avait mis une
pression sur ce fameux pions mais est
donc le gros avantage effectivement
d'avoir échangé d'avoir échangé une
paire de tours c'est que voilà l'accueil
le pion h peut être bien plus fort dans
plein de situations moyen tour millions
de pièces plus souple une fois mais il
ya des avantages et l'autre gros
avantage c'est que s'ils restent deux
paires de tous s'ils restent les deux
pères deux tours avec des tours en et
chouih tf1 quand le cac valeo 4 va
bouger peut toujours y avoir des tours
pour un f4 avec des idées de maths et
voilà donc là j'ai le roi beaucoup plus
serein grâce à cet échange de toi mais
d'accord donc ça c'est qu'est ce que
c'est subtil les différents 6 6 3 qu'il
a réussit tout avait si cette non
michael et ses 7 15 kw heure ci faisait
oui parce que je veux faire quel est des
deux caisses et c'est un coup
intéressant parce que l'idée c'est
surtout pensé qu'à d'affaires fois c'est
ce qui deviendra l'un des matériels
alors l'idée de calais 6 est un bon ben
ça ramène le cavalier vers le centre qui
est jamais une mauvaise idée parce que
leur ainsi s'il n'était pas facile mais
il était temps et nous parler mais c'est
vrai et le fou peut venir en a six et
regardez un assist qu'est-ce qu'il irait
dame donc si on prend avec la tour fois
ci cela tour s'il me le mène à la dame
est perdu donc en fait on va gagner en
qualité
donc on peut pas prendre ces quatre
voies la défense en direct quoi ça sert
un bon coup que j'avais raté d'ailleurs
parce que le tournage de son tout petit
j'ai même pas dans mon fichier tournage
débute je sais pas ok c est ce un bon
coup mais j'ai quand même
cavaillé d2 juste à temps il faut
absolument que la chercher au fond ces
quatre noms évidemment surtout le camion
c7 est bien placé et des fonctions aussi
ce n'était pas ce que c'est de jouer à
saint jean cette masse de profiteurs
quand même ici mais il faut vite c'est
en fait cette masse de pions au final
c'est resté comme ça c'est une
catastrophe
mais elle même d'un final de deroua la
sepur mon but adam et il soulève mais
presque exactement mais la grosse
différence c'est qu'une fois que
j'arrive à mettre une pièce en c4 d'un
coup les pions d'un coup les pions sont
complètement fixé et d'une la région
impressionnante ça devient ça devient un
bloc faiblesse inouïe il a joué il faut
assistante fois ci parce que s'il
échange des fous après je vais prendre
du cavalier sur ces 4 et là on peut pas
prendre
j'ai pris deux pions on prend avec le
cavaly bien sûr alors on est on est
cloué mais tout tient parce que deux
défenseurs deux attaquants mais on voit
pas comment les noirs peuvent attaquer
avec une pièce de plus s'il joue
cavalier des scènes par exemple pour
venir en b si ça marche pas parce que le
fou peut prendre sans doute parce qu'il
veut aussi à 1000 peux pas vous en échec
en plus anciens qui payent alors des
découvertes avec cavaliers baissé ses
charges si j'arrive à me dépêtrer de
cette loi après j'avais un gros avantage
et oui en plus et des découvertes si ce
cavalier bouge mais pour l'instant ce
qu'elle sait c'est vraiment une pièce
qui fait appliquer sa politique et ça
parce que ce cavalier là peut faire
échec aux 1 pascal adam attaque le fou
mais mais mais mais mais le cavaly ses
sept pour l'instant le protège et si
vous je sais pas pareil voilà donc la
crise s est une très bonne pièce parce
qu'il tient bien la colonne s'est éteint
le feu à six pour le problème avec les
blancs quand même joli position donc il
faut faire quelque chose sinon je vais
faire b3 au prochain co oui vous fourrez
f1 et ca consolidé
voilà une fois que je me sors de clouage
après la condition noire est très
difficile il faut bien pêche cette ville
a fait b3 pour essayer d'éviter la b3
empêche le pion b devenir en b3 donc ça
laisse les blancs avec ce système figé
très important d'avoir compris ça c'est
un petit coup qui a l'air de rien mais
qui est essentiel dans l'opposition on
dit c'est un coût qui est important
c'est peut-être la seule chance mondiale
te lâche obligé de faire chauffer fin
parce que sinon il n'y a pas d'autre
façon de me dépêtrer de ce que voilà
donc fouet fin tu rajoutes de la
protection c'est à dire que maintenant
gnafu dam tour qui protège de clad un
peu bougé il ya les défenseurs
mais la dame donc je lis vers madame en
fait ouais ok je vais d'amel 6 pour
avoir des vues sur le pion b2 peut-être
que d'amd 8 était une meilleure défense
parce qu'on disait après la partie à mon
égard dit ça peut-être d'être d'hamdi
meet up tu ne va rien même très vite été
possible est ici pourquoi ils menacent
arrivera il veut centraliser la table
sur 2,5 parce qu'il s'agirait en fait
d'un messi servait pas à grand chose vu
que
je vais bouger la dame et il faut
prendre ces quatre fers faut prendre ces
quatre il peut jamais prendre sur b2 oui
même des huit étaient sans doute une
meilleure défense c'est judas metois au
total des seuils comme quoi dam des
scènes qui est un problème majeur de la
pression aussi bien si denner avait le
temps de jeu même dessein que j'aurai
des gros problèmes parce qu'il y aurait
des problèmes sur le cahier c4 plus ou
bessette qui arrivait avec un match sur
la diagonale me faut qu'on voit ça
imaginons que les blues jouent par
exemple h5 mais là après d'amd 5 ça
commence à se retourner aurait
complètement dam des siens alors déjà
ont dévissé parce que si je vous dise le
foot je perds le cavalier ils y ont fait
simplement comprendre cavaliers puis si
ça attaque la dame
même si on prend la dame comprendre si
la dame ici donc on peut pas vraiment
bougé et le prochain coup les noirs font
par exemple consiste à montrer et
maintenant regarder up to b 7
il faut absolument voir ça sachant que
même ça c'est peut-être pas bon pour les
moeurs parce que j'aurai toujours f3
samat ici mais on peut pas réparer
freins f3 damage cinq ans ça commence
ça commence à quoi ça servait à le plan
est en fait un jeu quand il est très
bien et c'est bien de vouloir faire une
dame mais le moment où je le pousse il
faut faut que j'assure de mon cou parce
qu'après il devient faible sont éblouis
si tu perds tu perds tout l'avantagé
après que tu avais d'accords mets donc
il faut faire attention à ces idées là
les noirs sont pas sans ressources
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut être à la
fois rapides précis regarder tous les
détails que nous dit romain ce coup de
maître la tour à tous que la tour f
des choses comme ça qui sont très
difficiles à voir c'est pas humain
possible donc ici ou pas non mesdames
des buts je pense que je peux jouer que
par exemple par exemple d'un simplement
pour me retirer des clos à éviter tour d
un oui l'ami de tout le voir aussi
non mais je sais je pense pas évidemment
ça ça chez nos yeux les dalles congé
pensez simplement demeure il ya sans
doute d'autres coûts oui damien est
possible et dans ce cas là sur des cinq
maintenant j'ai le temps d'aller en
étroit avec le cavalier
bien tout tenir et après les pions c5 et
b3 vont être très faible je vais faire
de ces trois prochains qu est la dame
est attaquée faut bouger et ensuite les
chantres les fous là plus de menaces de
maths et finalement ses pions c'est
faible
tu va ramasser tout ce à quoi tu veux
venir à 5 avec la dame sur ces trois
entraînements de toute façon c'est
important pour les meneurs de garder des
initiatives et de ne pas laisser les
blancs et changer les pièces comme ça
parce que sinon sinon ça c'est chou dont
le gros atout et puis en b3 c'est à dire
que tant que le clan b3 et là je peux
pas te le permettre avec les blancs
parce que parfois après l'ouverture des
deux tours en d2 donc ici vous dame âgée
de six ans après voilà près d'1 me 3 il
ya plus d'un an le nombre moyen de
défendre le plan b 3 dames 3 donc là on
peut maintenant qui grâce à cette
surprotection du cavalier préalable la
dame est libéré et maintenant on attaque
ce fan opium b3 qui était ce qui était
essentiel qui va qui tombe donc du coup
ces hommes qui ont déjà dit après on
pourra arriver tellement sûr consolider
le cavalier éventuellement tarbes et
rend enfin bon c'est bien pour les
blancs quoi c'est une bonne nouvelle est
donc là déjà
là cette valise il a joué d'amd 8 pour
finalement quand même venir en d5
alors si je capture le pion b3 c'est
sans doute bien aussi mais après dam des
5 alors que le prix n'en a pas pris par
exemple alors si je prends vraiment pour
la brillante que je lis voilà effet
d'amd 5
oui mais alors je peux toujours jouer
des coups comme f3 c'est pas si grave
mais voilà c'était quelque chose que je
voulais pas concéder faut pas jouer sous
bédié est alors justement c'est ça que
je lui fous j'ai deux donc si les normes
on vous prend ces cut jeu c'est fou
prend 2,5 alors contre attaque le la
dame est attaqué il faut aux échecs il
faut éviter de perdre du temps en contre
attaque
en prônant une pièce et la fondation n'a
pas le choix il faut prendre la dame
mais dans ce cas là vous prendre les 3
es là le faux et le temps de reprendre
sur b3 et donc le film est assez bon
pour les blancs hélas les blogueurs les
blancs gagnent puisque si on compte les
pions on a eu besoin de plus jean marie
fils et ses 5 qui est valable et s'était
en revanche on repassera
après le coup j'ai deux en revanche
après tu reprends ckt cigale pour les
marques
ah bon ah si je suis parce que faut
prendre md5 alors tout reprend ici mais
l'antique fou prend évidemment sa soirée
nature est seul on a perdu une pièce
parce que si je prends de reprendre la
dame s'est terminée tout à fait donc
sous prend dame pour penser un échec
celui de cavaliers feront des 5 l et
noir ont gagné une tour et de pièces
pour la dame on va jouer par roger de
droite ou de gauche 2 peu importe il a
regardé le matos dames contre tours fou
les cavaliers c'est pense à faire cher
parce que trois fouilles crusher trois
plus trois pour le cavalier fou ça fait
6 plus saine pour la tour ça fait onze
de la dame sait que 10 mais en plus on
considère que trois pièces c'est
vraiment très salée ps car sont vraiment
hyper active après fo bessette je vais
avoir des problèmes et bien sûr le roi
donc ça c'est sûr que ça va pas du tout
pour les blancs ça va pas du tout donc
c'était quand même il fallait calcul
liste va faire un petit peu attention
oui
il ya des pièges tout le temps hockey
ici sur les touches de yossi cavaliers à
5 par exemple pour échanger les dames on
peut essayer cavaliers à 5
encore une variante je pense aux proches
des chances de dames
je pense que le mieux ici et fo prend
enfin prises des 5 en finale est
probablement gagnante pour les blancs
bloqué à l'ail a dû gagner des lots du
boulot et il va york quelques coups
faciles à jouer pour les noirs donc du
coup voilà pendant la partie j'avais pas
envie de rentrer là dedans d'accord j'ai
pas pris tout de suite le plan b 3 donc
du coup on revienne en été parce que tu
veux tu ne veux pas prendre directoire à
cause de ses variantes qui sont encore
un peu tendance tu pense qu'elle est une
arme plus forte ici qui est je jouais
dame c3 que l'âme c3 on va dire un coup
de stabilisation l'idée c'est d'avoir la
case de 3 pour le cavalier à voilà donc
tu libères à presque toute cette panique
maintenant la dame en plus si m6 et
l'isle adam ans avec une option c'est le
calicot venir en 3 d éliminer souffre ou
dangereux pourquoi il est dangereux
parce qu'on est en namibie pions sur
noir donc il ya un tout petit peu sa vie
si un jour le plan le faut peu revient
sur bessette et créer quelques petits
problèmes on veut changer c'est pourquoi
est ici s'il fait d'amd 5g cavaliers de
3 alors si par exemple dam des scènes
pour les noirs pour jouer foule 17
cavaliers tout simplement tuer les trois
tacles adam et le fouet fm à s'échanger
contre le faire et c'est ça que b3 vent
tombé à 6 septembre et dont et s'il
commence par trouver sa taule il devait
s'incliner 4 à 5 alors s'ils jouent sous
bessette une autre possibilité donc là
on s'enlève dehors du coup on abandonne
tout
voilà mais l'idée c'est à dire d'un
secteur dam des 5 et donc la cavale et à
5 pour aller chercher ce fou et après je
vais prendre le pion ses sommets yvan
invite ensuite ten des cinq essais mat
voilà maintenant que pendant ces 5 alors
par exemple peu fou à 8
mais regardez maintenant il ya touré
dame sur la colonne c'est le pion c5 et
en plus donc simplement de dame prend et
comme il ya presque maths on peut pas
bouger la dame et voilà donc on est
coincé c'est les blancs qui sont plus
actifs que le noir et c'est pas la même
donc on revient c'est pas ça donc d'un
de ses trois qu'est ce qui fait bien
jouer autour des rails avait pas
l'arrivée par d'autres mazout est
d'accord ton visage est simple il veut
éliminer la tour ouais d'accord
j'appréhendais en prison j'ai joué
cavalier de troie d'un prend cavaliers 3
un peu la même idée tout à l'heure mais
la différence ici c'est que le le fou
bien sûr est fin et tout est à dire qu
on ne veut pas prendre à 6 puisque la
tam fry chèque
donc il va garder la dame sur la
première voilà mais sachant qu'il y a
pas de casse pour défendre le clan b3
qui comme utiliser le gros atout de la
position nord n'en veut pas des craintes
de choses des jeux dame un pourvoyeur de
dames et sudha me prend b3 donc pour
immobiliser le fou et puis avoir mené
sur l'a4 monçao sa force d'un plan mais
trop étroit juste beaucoup
ouais bien joué ces quatre alors si si
je jouais qu'à l'aller des cinq élèves
le jour c'est être celle où on a vu ça
en direct puisque ces quatre bus
complètement sont tous ouais le problème
c'est que sur cavaliers des cinq qui
avait l'air en vidéo naturel oui je peux
faire simplement d'amener un meilleur
état d'âme à croire expliqué on
expliquer pourquoi ces natures et
câble et des cinq effectivement mais
naturelle pourquoi parce que d'abord si
lecavalier prend il ya dame prend fou
puisque regarder le roi ici ne peut pas
prendre la dame à cause du fou à 6 j'ai
montré sa tournée donc en fait ce cas
les décès qui attaquent le défenseur du
fou voilà donc c'est une menace
et là tu me dit-elle temps de faire de
me dire oui mais là il est forcé
d'échangés vdn parce que sinon que je
vais prendre assez sûr et j'ai fait la
finale donc avec le pion h4 est plus
voilà le fait et n'oubliez pas cher
diriger l'échangé fou et emprises la
dame aussi donc il faut faire des
échanges
voilà et là c'est gagnant ça devrait
être assez facile grâce non seulement le
temps plus mais surtout le dire que ce
soit ses pions achats le temps passe et
il ya encore du grain peu de boulot mais
ça valait le problème c'est qu'avec un
peu plus de finale 2 km puis à
l'occasion des 16èmes de finale depuis
que le matériel est décisif le problème
c'est que par exemple après le faux
prêtre un rabbin f1 après je gagne aussi
plein de temps sur le canadien avec
cavaliers au 3 ou cavaliers de cette 3d
nord doivent toujours reculer oui parce
que dès qu'un échange ce pion et plus
rapide que le roi et façon si le roi va
chercher le pion jeu pendant ce temps le
roi blanc on va beaucoup baisser scène
puis b4 dessins qui ont fait dame très
rapidement donc il faut être comme il
faut bien connaître les finales de pions
mais amusez-vous d'ailleurs à jouer
cette finale contre des amis votre
ordinateur ça vous entraînera à
comprendre pourquoi cette finale est
archi quatre hommes sur les blancs il
n'y a rien de mieux que de s'exercer
donc alors ici
donc il ne fait pas cavalier des 5 à
cause de deux millions oui la fessée 4
griffer ckd parce qu'il peut pas jouer
en corse ou bessède par exemple 17 17 le
problème c'est que cela j'ai toutes les
menaces je vais faire simplement par
exemple d'homme c3 et je vais aller
chercher deux fiancés simple dames ces
trois attaques le pion ses seins qui
comme ses deux d'ailleurs plutôt pour
éviter que le pion aux cats on trees et
même voix la dame ces deux hommes
puisque dame ces deux joueurs contrôlent
toujours un cadenas peut pas prendre et
de pioncer 5 et 7 ans prier montrant
qu'il est en plus si les noirs ne font
rien j'avance tranquillement toujours
fermathe pour faire dame pardon donc on
revient il peut pas non plus donc du
coup s'éclate peut-être sur le coup
quand même non mais vraiment c'est un
peu foutu quoi donc ces quatre
évidemment alors pourquoi moi ça me fait
pas plaisir ce coup parce qu'il vient je
bouffe toute l'action vous pouvez
installer à gérer le pion mais j'aurais
pu aussi faire d'un b 4 par exemple
whitney big bang et a pris oui j'ai pris
avec le cavalier et là tu menaces
qu'elles aient des six échecs
non je me l'a simplement par exemple
damas trois ou la possession agit dans
ma 3 pour pour vous et les chants des
dames puisque le cavalier protégé par le
fou aussi élevé après damas trois
realplayer des trucs effet un peu plus
élevé
le set avec des six en hémato signe donc
que là bas qu'est ce qui peut faire et
je vais car il y ait des cinq encore je
vais simplement damas trois pour aller
changer les dames ont évidemment la
finale est encore plus futur tout à
l'air de pions pour toi et je vais te
laisser un ouais je vais dame ces cinq
échecs et voilà donc mais c'est le cas
du roi et b 8 parce que sinon je vais
faire une découverte avec le cas alors
si bien en 17
il ya par exemple cavaliers cheikh naji
rendez la dame et ont prise ou alors
d'amd 62.6 aussi et d'amd six échecs
aussi ah oui donc si vie en dix huit
c'est un de ces dames des six échecs roi
bouge et hop le fou regarde donc le seul
coup facile la maison à 10,8 par
élimination même dé ses échecs car même
si cette force l échec
alors là pour défendre le foule massée
sur web et sept sur akalé à 5 échelle le
fou à 6 et attaquer donc siro 17
cavaliers échec lors à bout j'ai regardé
la dame ensuite prend le x 6 il n'y a
pas il n'y a pas on peut pas sauver tout
ça donc ils obligés de revenir avec le
cavalier qui en plus bon un petit oeil
sur le fou j'ai fait d'un bep quatre
échecs et un réseau d'hommes de maths
qui arrive prix échec il l'a fait roi
c'est 8
il faut revenir ensuite est-ce qu'il
peut pas aller en évitera ça change rien
je fais dans ma fuite dans tous les cas
d'accord donc ici là maintenant dames et
suite aux lancers francs 17 cavaliers
aux cinq matches où il faut le voir ça
il doit aller sur 17
alors si on doit on le montre quand même
vers saint-lô limmat
sirois 17 regardez ça c'est
il est pas souvent suis là cavalier e 5
matches incroyables regarder avec dan et
cabello fait maths on le dit d'ailleurs
souvent que dame et cavalli contre roy
c'est monstrueux
ouais bon là en l'occurrence un peu le
cavaly fait tchèque et en plus contrôler
la casse et 6 et la dame contrôler
toutes les autres cases et évidemment le
cavalier bouche la sortie du roi 1 jeudi
les avantages de ramener de cabine et
grâce à cette jolie matt donc du coup ce
n'est pas le soir tous les ans 17 mais
maintenant ils allaient même de l'autre
côté avec cavaliers à cinq échecs ça
c'est la partie
donc là maintenant cavalier assène qu'un
échec au roi et l'abandonné parce que
seront abaissées si adam des quatre
échecs
alors on va montrer ça pourquoi ils
abandonnent tous assez pris le la casse
et si ces prises par le cavalier simple
le roi bessette est en échec
il reste trois en b6 ce goût et l'a donc
d'un de mes quatre échecs 2004 échec il
émet un son budget d'interposer une
pièce sur 25
voilà laurent n'a pas de case les cases
ici sont prises par le cavalier donc il
faut donner un domaine pièce on va tous
travailler là par l'allemand je vais en
tout simplement gagné une pièce et en
plus il peut même pas reprendre puisque
c'est quelle partie technique commun
oui ça c'est assez joué ça je sais jouer
à des détails il a il a alors comment tu
comment tu fais toi comme ça quand tu
joues une variante comme jules ou sarah
vendant une partie préalable et que tu
perds est ce que tu vois là quand même
essayer de rejouer comme il avait comme
il devait le faire là où est-ce que tu
tentes absolument 2
rice ça dépend de sa dépense et j'ai
confiance en ouverture que le jeu
variante un petit peu
un petit peu douteuse jeu plutôt ne pas
la répéter mais voilà pourquoi si on a
bien analysé quelque chose maintenant
faire une partie on a envie d'améliorer
sa partie en fait là il a perdu contre
andré soit et secoue un peu
maladroitement il a juste l'inversé de
coûts dans l'ouverture du coup et là il
a il a eu envie de les répéter mais
voilà du coup c'est pas trop de chance
pour lui parce que non seulement il a
perdu maladroitement mais en plus
derrière comme je disais j'ai pu réviser
certainement une autre partie si j'avais
pas si je n'ai pas toujours eu ce matin
quoi alors maintenant que tu es un peu
revenu dans ce tournoi après cette
victoire
quel est ton ambition pour la suite dont
le combat commence très mal
deux sur quatre c'est pas avec trois
blancs et que les adversaires un à ma
classe s et d'élus presque
catastrophique mais voilà c'était
important c'était important de gagner
deux parties g
j'ai le dernier rideau du tournoi mais
ça nous réussit pas toujours les mains
des lots comme ça dans les tournois
fermé voit la main j'ai un certain
nombre de parties difficiles car et je
vais jouer notamment les numéros 1 2 4
avec les noirs bon de dire je joue
partie par partie
voilà évidemment je dirais pas que j'y
crois des masses après ce début mais
voilà je vais faire de mon mieux chaque
jour
il suffit d'une série des x pour se
relancer une victoire importante avec
les noix ou quelque chose comme ça mais
c'est reparti mais bon voilà c'est n'est
vraiment pas de points faciles platon
facile dans ce tournoi c'est pour ça que
c'est encore plus rageant de m'être un
pan entier à la poubelle dès le début de
tour est ce que le national c'est plus
dur que d'autres tournois de mus et les
français donc qu'ils se connaissent
mieux que d'autres joueurs et donc ils
connaissent plus les forces et les
faiblesses des uns des autres oiseaux
différent ça peut être un avantage comme
un désavantage
tu lui préfère te retourne aux autres ou
comment tu comment tu l'abord de ce
tournoi est ce que ça fait partie
préférée mais j'aime bien l'étendre à
fermer parce que j'ai tendance à me
ramasser au premier rang dans les hôtels
qui ont déjà beaucoup moins bien classés
donc voilà j'ai même j'ai gagné j'ai
fait premier ex-aequo d'un du world open
aux états unis au mois de juillet et en
finissant premier ex-aequo d'internât
les plus réputés au monde cherche à
perdre des points elo parce que j'ai
commencé par an et demi sur soi voilà
c'est un peu c'est un peu ma hantise des
premières entre deux tournois du coup ok
c'est bon j'ai aussi perdu la rondelle
j'ai pas perdu contre un joueur à 2200
comme comme aux états unis j'ai perdu
contre un grand m voilà même si le tas
temps dans la partie était plat musan tu
sais voilà je préfère au moins sait pas
faire jouer ce genre de partie pour
commencer que jouer et pour la suite
alors pour les prochains mois l'équipe
de france il ya des rendez vous prévus
ou plus ou si plus tard alors avec le
championnat d'europe des nations c'est
un mois novembre à jaca vic avec dd si
la junte ont à charge et bien avec la
coupe du monde cap d'agde donc oui gros
calendrier lors un gros gros calendrier
ça ça va s'enchaîner scène parce que
c'est des gros gros tournoi ça plus donc
ce championnat d'europe qui dit whitt
championnat d'europe des nations
donc si chaud gros calendrier grosse
préparation beaucoup de parties à jouer
encore beaucoup la vie des grands
maîtres c'est beaucoup de travail
finalement un devant son ordinateur en
préparation
avant les tournois c'est pas que je
travaille toute l'année voilà merci
beaucoup
un roman noir de passer sur notre
émission voilà je vous donne rendez vous
la prochaine fois pour une nouvelle
mission des modèles tv torse nationale
51 2015 pour suivre la suite des ces
nationaux passionnant merci au revoir à
bientôt
au revoir